we live in a segregated culture and I
don't mean segregated racially though
the left is certainly working on that I
mean that it's segregated generationally
the younger Generations have their own
culture their own language their own art
their own music their own Universe to
themselves which exists almost entirely
online it shouldn't be like this and it
wasn't always like this but in the
internet age this cultural bifurcation
of young and old is only getting worse
and kids have their own celebrities too
these are people who gain tens of
millions of fans even hundreds of
millions of fans young fans and become
household names for younger people so
they're household names among the the
children in the household but not the
adults while remaining almost entirely
Anonymous to anyone over the age of say
30 or 25. a prime example of this is
YouTube Star Mr Beast and the YouTuber
known as Mr beast real name Jimmy
Donaldson has 145 million subscribers on
the platform that's just that's just for
his primary Channel Donaldson also has
several offshoot Channel each boasting
millions of additional subscribers on
his main Channel Donaldson has three
times as many subscribers as Taylor
Swift twice as many as Justin Bieber in
fact he has more subscribers than every
pop star more than every internet
personality more than every Media or
Entertainment Company aside from Sony's
India division that one hasn't beat but
other than that
he has the most he is he is massively
successful wildly famous
and yet I hadn't heard of him until a
few months ago I spent much of my day
online for my job unfortunately I also
have a YouTube channel of my own which
feels suddenly quite obscure by
comparison but I've only just recently
become Vaguely Familiar with Mr Beast
and even now I wouldn't recognize the
guy if he passed me on the sidewalk it
is to say the least very troubling that
someone can become this prominent among
younger generations and have this much
influence over them and yet be so
obscure to the rest of us
if you're a parent and you've made the
mistake of giving your child open access
to the internet you're placing an
enormous amount of faith in these
influencers who are influencing your
kids
it is a faith that is almost always or
really always misplaced because even the
most family-friendly content the most
seemingly innocuous as most of Mr
BEAST's content appears to be
can subtly or not so subtly introduce
Concepts
that will take your child down a very
dark path
in the case of Mr Beast that path has
been opened by his sidekick and co-star
on his videos named Chris Tyson Tyson's
a frequent collaborator with Mr Beast
and an internet celebrity in his own
right with nearly 14 million subscribers
across Tick Tock Twitter and Instagram
and he appears in many of Mr B's videos
it's very familiar to fans of the
channel
and those fans most of them kids again
have been watching over the last few
months as Tyson has transformed himself
from a married man with a child to
something that is supposed to look like
some sort of approximation of a woman
fans had noticed for several weeks as
Tyson underwent a sort of bizarre
physical change not only growing his
hair out but beginning to appear
increasingly frail and sickly and
started wearing women's clothes and all
the rest of it finally last week Tyson
came out as trans and confirmed that
he's been on hormone replacement therapy
for the past two months
explaining his decision Tyson tweeted
quote informed consent HRT saved my and
many others lives the hurdles GNC gender
non-conforming people have to jump
through to get life-saving gender
affirming Health Care in a first world
country is wild to me just let people
make informed decisions about their own
bodies
in response to uh the concerns some
people have raised about the effect his
transition quote unquote might have on
his young son Tucker Tyson said quote I
know I'm going to be a great parent and
so is every other person who puts the
love of their child before everything I
made this decision because I wanted to
show up as my best and happiest self for
him in a way this was for Tucker
now we'll return in a moment to the
grotesque and laughable claim that he's
destroying his body and denying his own
manhood for the sake of his son for the
sake of his son he says he's doing it
but first we have Mr BEAST's own
reaction to all of this yesterday he
sent out a tweet blasting those who've
raised concerns about having a
transition in quote unquote man appear
constantly in videos meant for kids he
called it absurd and said that called
the concerns absurd that is and said
that all this transphobia is starting to
piss me off
now admittedly
Mr Beast has been put in an extremely
difficult situation because he built a
multi-million dollar Empire with
innocuous family-friendly content
targeted at kids and now his friend and
collaborator and sidekick has decided to
turn these videos into a sort of visual
Journal of his gender transition
so Mr Beast has a choice he can either
kick Tyson off of the team and then be
excoriated as a transphobe or he can
come out fully in favor of
transgenderism and he can stay therefore
in The Graces of the the good graces of
the media and LGBT activists even if it
means alienating a huge portion of his
fan base
especially the parents of his fan base
well unsurprisingly he chose the latter
and now that he's gone down this road
there's really no coming back you can
expect much more pro-trans content from
Mr Beast going forward which means that
if you're a parent and you allow your
child to watch Mr Beast videos now is a
very good time to stop allowing that
we could probably assume that Mr Beast
would prefer not to have to deal with
this but Tyson has forced him to make a
choice and uh and he chose and he chose
wrong
this is really the common thread Tyson
is forcing this onto people who are
close to him forcing it in more ways
than one a few months ago Tyson posted a
photo of his young son in high heels
with the caption quote Tucker chose to
slay this morning
it's only a matter of time we can assume
before we start hearing about Tucker's
own quote unquote gender transition
Journey a journey which Tyson will claim
that Tucker chose for himself but we can
clearly see who is making the choices
here
as for his wife Katie we can surmise how
she feels about all this based on the
fact that she is divorcing her husband
Tyson announced just a couple of weeks
before coming out as trans or non-binary
or whatever that uh that he and his wife
had separated and were working on quote
unquote finalizing things so if you're
keeping score at home
Chris Tyson has destroyed his marriage
abandoned his child to a broken home
created huge problems for his friend and
business partner potentially costing him
millions of subscribers and therefore
millions of dollars and he has done all
of this
just so that he could live out his
fantasies in public
he had a beautiful wife a child a family
an incredible job that most people would
kill for which had made him wealthy and
famous and and he pulled the pin and and
chucked a hand grenade into the middle
of that happy and Serene picture and for
what
all so that he can be his quote happiest
self he claims
and he achieves his happiest self by
rejecting his actual self
and all the responsibilities that his
actual self is Duty bound to fulfill
now Tyson is of course just the latest
in a long line of grown married men who
decide to come out as trans or
non-binary this was Rachel Levine's
story this is really a story of some of
those prominent trans activists in the
country I think grown men who transition
after they've already had kids and and
are married this is a demographic that
is uh that is vastly over represented
among trans activists
now we know that you know a great many
of the people who identify as quote
unquote trans you know you're talking a
lot of this there's this this is a
because of Rapid onset gender dysphoria
and the social contagion Factor there's
many adolescent girls who get caught up
in this
um but when it comes to the activists
it seems that a hugely disproportionate
number of them are men
and especially Men Who quote unquote
transitioned when they were already
adults so Tyson is then a valuable
example because he reveals an important
truth about the trans phenomenon
despite what we are so often told
the decision to transition is not
personal and private
okay it's not some sort of harmless
personal decision it's not like you're
you're you know choosing an ice cream
flavor at Baskin Robbins
okay that's a decision where you can
rightly say to anybody who has an
opinion about it hey this doesn't affect
you okay what do you care
that's not this
you're doing something that will have a
dramatic life-altering devastating
effect on those who are closest to you
this is not a private Journey that you
walk alone you are dragging others with
you whether they want to go or they
don't and almost always they don't
indeed all of Western Society has been
dragged into this we are all impacted
and profoundly so by individuals who
refuse to accept reality and live as
themselves
but those who are closest to the uh
impact site will feel it the most
and many of them will end up buried
under the rubble
starting first and foremost with the
families
this is why a you know a grown man like
Chris Tyson
who makes this choice
really does not deserve our sympathy or
our understanding
I know saying that will probably get me
in trouble yet again with many on the
right who say well we've got to be
sympathetic and nice about this
um not to these people
because he is engaging in the ultimate
Act of family wrecking narcissism
it is the deepest betrayal of his
marriage vows
of his responsibility as a husband and a
father
and even worse he's dismantling his
family in a way that Society approves of
which means that his wife can't object
to the total demolition of her family
and her marriage she can't cry out in
anger or sadness while her husband takes
a wrecking ball to her life
without being labeled a transphobe and a
bigot
which is probably why she's remained
silent through all this as far as I know
she hasn't said anything publicly
she's not even afforded the Dignity of
her grief
she is deprived of the right to be angry
about this terrible thing that has been
done to her
okay you're a grown adult man you have a
wife and you transition that is
something you are doing to your wife
and to yourself but also to your wife
a man who has an affair you know and
leaves his wife for another woman at
least that guy has the decency to wreck
his marriage in a way that allows his
wife to hate him for it and her anger
will be validated by Society
men like men like Chris do the same kind
of thing yet they do it in a manner that
calls for the wife's understanding
you know very often we hear about men
who transition with their wives alleged
support and yet the details don't really
add up so for example a woman named
Deborah tweeted this to me yesterday in
response to one of my tweets she said
quote my best friend Katie transitioned
with the full support of her spouse and
in fact they still live together even
though they're officially divorcing not
everyone has the same story this is
quite a beautiful story I'm proud to
have Katie as my friend
hmm
um
yes his spouse fully supports it she
thinks it's great
I mean really she's so happy about it
she really is also on a totally
unrelated note they're getting a divorce
because that's obviously what you do
when your spouse makes a decision that
you absolutely support you divorce them
for it
obviously the claims about supportive
wives are always fictional in these
cases I mean always
that in every case
when a married man decides to quote
unquote transition the wife does not
support it and I don't care what the
wife says about it publicly she doesn't
support it and I know that because
these women married men
okay they didn't marry some kind of
vague ambiguous notion of a person
they didn't just say oh I'm marrying a
person it doesn't matter what they are
or what they look like or anything just
it's just a person
no they married men
with definite characteristics both
physical and not it is a form of
Abandonment the worst form in fact to
intentionally strip away and attempt to
change everything about yourself that
your wife thought she married
I mean to to deliberately attempt to
become the opposite of what you are and
what your wife married
it is again an extreme betrayal of your
marriage vows
you are taking your wife's husband away
from her you're taking your child's
father away from him
and the best you can do to justify that
decision is to say that it makes you
happy
so even by your own telling even
according to your own rationalization
you are choosing your happiness over the
needs and desires and the happiness of
your family
see here's the thing
here's the thing transitioning is wrong
always and every time uh first because
it's impossible you cannot transition
from one sex to the other but even if we
lived in the sort of Science Fiction
Universe where such a thing was possible
it would still be wrong to do it when
you're married and you have a child
like if I believed in the reality of
transitioning I would still say that by
the time you get married and conceive a
child the transition ship has sailed
it is your responsibility now it's your
obligation to suppress that part of you
and live as the man that your wife and
child need you to be
but it's not possible
and so the reality is so much worse
you're setting it all on fire you're
burning your life to the ground
in pursuit of something you can never
Attain
that you had something you had something
real and beautiful and now you have
nothing nothing but a fantasy
figment of your imagination
but but at least you're happy right
except even your happiness is fake your
happiness is as real as your Womanhood
you aren't happy
nobody is now
that was a trade-off
and it's never worth it and that'll do
it for the show or for this portion of
shows move over to members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you Monday
have a great weekend Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]